ja meine lieben damen und herren das ist
mein ziel
das ist die zukunft und die zukunft ist
jetzt oder wie man im arabischen sagte
schiller herder herrsche aber die erde
würden sie mich dann sonntag wählen
ich glaube ich bin da ganz ehrlich ich
bin bereit für kompromisse ich sage zum
beispiel schächten ja aber nur weil ich
sage hochzeitskuss ja aber nur scooter
heiliger krieg ja aber nur gegen preußen
ich sage von gleichberechtigung wäre zu
viel des guten aber ich würde durchsetzt
und dass frauen nicht mehr arbeiten
müssen weil eine frau hat nämlich nicht
zu arbeiten
ich danke die frauen lieben mich diese
menschen die religiös überhaupt religiös
sind sowieso so gestellt dass man sagt
wir haben keinen so hohen
intelligenzquotienten hätten sie dann
tipps für mich was ich hier nicht machen
darf im gasthof als muslim dass er sich
das nicht negativ auffallen nicht trinkt
ein bier das ist der haken ich denke das
ist das ist schlecht da kam es in bayern
nicht
wie ist das wenn zb in istanbul sich ein
bekennender katholik zum bürgermeister
wählen lassen möchte dann bewegen muss
im rahmen der science fiction
die zukunft trocken bleibt und mir keine
parkgebühren wieder aber die dame war
mir wird schneller grün machen sie am
sonntag deshalb nun eine richtige stelle
und dann sagt man für frei
ein laut der zustimmung oder des
einvernehmens warum reden sie den
kreuzworträtsel ein laut der zustimmung
oder des einvernehmens freilich
weil ich fest dass ich grüße sie
ich grüße sie ich habe christian
verstanden ich verstehe euch rechten ich
verdammte scheiße menschen werden mich
wählen deren sprache ich gar nicht
verstehe
hätten sie interesse an einem
handyvertrag glücklich hier diese
halbmond irgendwie vertraut haben können
sie wirklich wo im monat die ganze
familie im ausland anrufen bin in mein
handy ganz selten her einer der mich
fest gezeigt ich habe auch festnetz
verträge danke landshut csu und moslem
da haben sich zwei gefunden es wächst
zusammen was zusammengehört
schweinsbraten mit feiner soße einfach
90 bei dem preis warum nicht
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
last ich hab die schnauze voll los lasst
ein abo da